welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka mr eight minute
video
so i can get more youtube ads in it and
something has been itching away
at the back of my mind on thursday i did
a big video discussing all of the things
in loki that
probably won't come true and this
included a lot of talking points
amongst these were why the post-credits
scene might just be a garbage timeline
people get sent to and pruned
and also how ravona rensslayer may be a
loki variant
lots of clickbait however one thing i
said flippantly
actually seems more and more likely the
more i think about it
what if the big bad of the entire show
has been hiding in plain sight this
entire time
and it is possible that miss minutes may
be the one controlling the tva since
saying it i've had a lot of people reach
out to me
saying they agree and men's health even
did an article about it so if it turns
out to be untrue
then i'm gonna lose everything my
reputation my house
everything i'm gonna lose it however
yeah i think there might be a lot of
characteristics that she portrays
which could demonstrate exactly why she
is the one pulling the strings
now just talking about things on a meta
level miss minutes is a brand new
character that hasn't featured in the
comics before
because of this her inclusion doesn't
give anything away
and it's weird that they would invent a
whole character just to have them
basically do a psa in episode 1
and a couple of lines in episode 2.
behind her vocal performance is taurus
strong
an a-lister when it comes to voice
actors and she's portrayed harley quinn
batgirl the powerpuff girls and a lot of
characters
she's a big name in the industry that i
think most people will have heard of
before
and it seems strange that they'd get her
in to just do a couple of lines
for what is seemingly an insignificant
character now next we have to talk about
what her role in the tva
is i've been talking to ryan airy from
screencrush about this
and yes spoiler alert we do actually get
on well
which no doubt will confirm many fan
theories that our listeners have
now we've gone back and forth over the
individual role of miss minutes
and how she's central to the tva
restoring order amongst the chaos that
is existence
in episode 1 miss minutes presents the
introduction that details all the ins
and outs of the timekeepers
who we learn a machine simply put in
place to keep up the facade
in the second entry we see that she's
very much been propped up to make sure
that the variants follow her guidelines
in order to ensure that the sacred
timeline is kept in place
she clearly controls the messaging the
propaganda if you will
and in a fascist state that is where the
majority of power lies
the only way to have people follow a
leader like they're a deity
is to present them as one and miss
minutes is central to this messaging
the tva themselves are all put in place
to blindly follow orders
and we also see through minutes that she
can appear on any tv screen in the
organization
or even upon people's desks if she needs
to the way that she works and the powers
that she possesses
is something that has a lot of question
marks surrounding it
and at the moment we still have no clue
exactly how she operates
ishii live streaming issue recording
that looks at people's responses after
an event and edits herself to continue
this loop of actions
we just don't know but yeah either way
something is off about her
she seems like a cute and cuddly
character with a disarming southern
accent
however there is a darker side to her we
get a hint towards this during episode 1
when we see a poster that says behave or
you'll get your clock cleaned
this has an image of her stamping on
someone which is something that is often
used in propaganda to present power
those that step out of line and don't
behave in the way that she wants them to
are pruned
and the idea of her being powerful is
clearly laced throughout this scene
interestingly in the episode before loki
joins the queue
they scan to see if he's a robot we
learn that those that are
are immediately wiped out and this could
be because a robot might have the
capability to scan its environment
and it would immediately see if the
timekeepers are mechanical or not
being a machine herself miss minutes
would know this
so she would likely want to erase all
possibility of a robot coming face to
face with her
right before the variance 2 for the
first time now going beyond this clocks
are of course central to not only time
but the tva itself they are constantly
watching over the timeline
and thus a clock being in charge of how
time plays out makes a lot of sense on a
symbolic level
clocks of course mark time in a linear
fashion with everything flowing in one
strict direction
thus her being behind it lines up a lot
with the way that clocks work
the entire tva city 2 looks like the
inner workings of a clock
and there are a lot of gears and people
all in their specific place so that
overall the timeline can continue to
move in a certain direction
we can also see on the elevator panel
that there is a floor which goes
directly to her
and this could be foreshadowing where
the finale takes place
on top of this is the fact that the
timekeepers themselves are robots
and we know that she is connected to
them in some way
besides them she's the only other power
figure in the organization
and the fact that they're fugazi leaves
her as the only thing left in a position
to control things
now every time i've told this theory to
someone they've either said you
you son of a [ __ ] you've done it or
said that it sucks
i think this is because she's basically
just a talking clock
and people want someone big like kang
the conqueror whilst this is true and i
have been on board the kang train myself
i'm just looking at the pieces that are
currently on the board and
we have been introduced to miss minutes
whereas he's something that probably
won't be in the show
now some big spoilers from one of the
trailers going forward
so if you want to go into the upcoming
episodes as blind as possible
then i highly recommend that you prune
yourself from the timeline also if
you've enjoyed the theories and the
thumbs up is much appreciated
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns on the show each and every
week
now if you're still here yet thank you
for sticking with me and staying in line
with the kang theory
it may be revealed that minutes is
actually an avatar for the villain
in either the fifth or sixth episode we
do know that mobius heads out to egypt
and fans of the comics will know this
ties in heavily with kang's backstory
over the years he's gone by many names
including ramatut
which was his pseudonym when he reigned
as a pharaoh in ancient egypt
nathaniel richards to give him his birth
name was born in the 30th century
however he ended up using a time machine
to travel back to 2960 bc
here he left several things including a
prophecy about apocalypse
aka the first mutant and he also took
over a vast kingdom
kang was able to do this with ease
through his highly advanced technology
and it does make a lot of sense that
mobius would travel there to learn about
him
now overall this would allow the show to
have its main villain be presented in a
certain way
without coming out and saying exactly
who it is if miss minutes is revealed to
be the one behind it all and then we get
someone behind that
it does tease enough for the future
without making it so that the audience
who aren't aware of kang
aren't completely lost they can still
watch the show and see the seeds sown
before the big reveal
and for me that makes the most sense
especially now we know how marvel tend
to set their villains
up in these shows either way there's a
lot to talk about in this video
and if it turns out to be untrue then
i'm wiping everyone's memories who's
watched this
so never bring it up again until then
though i'd love to hear your thoughts on
these theories
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize through on the 30th of july
in which we pick three people who get an
mcu boxer of their choice
all you have to do to be with a chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
those other theories which will be
linked on screen right now
a lot better than this video as i didn't
do the editing for it
so definitely go and watch it and just
have a great time seeing how many things
i get wrong
now without the way thank you for
singing through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time
take care peace